carlos martinez the right-hander for st
louis start number seven this year two
and four record 3.72 the earned run
average ryan mcmahon left-handed hitting
second baseman this afternoon
mack hitting 264 on the year he rips one
fair inside the first base bag
tapia was running on the play and he is
going to score it's an rbi double for
ryan mcmahon and the rockies jump on top
early one to nothing
now charlie blackmon pretty impressive
list right there he's third all time the
rocky's hit list and
oh what a play on a short hop by tommy
edmond my goodness
is there anything that this young man
cannot do here's garrett hampson hampson
is hit safely in sixth straight
the pitch
a high fly ball and that's hit deep left
center field vader got a good jump he's
over waits for it makes the catch hanson
just got under that one right-hander
chi-chi gonzalez for the rockies 1-0
4.38 era it'll be start number five
appearance number seven
so runners at the corners nobody out
here's paul goldschmidt
runners at the corners the 1-1 pitch for
paul goldschmidt base it to right field
we're tied at one edmond scores carlson
stops at second
three singles right out of the gate
edmund carlson goldschmidt one to one
aldi young went over four with two
strikeouts in game one of the series
last night and he's batting with second
and third one out
a swing and a line drive hit into center
field scoring dylan carlson goldsmith
stops at third the cardinals lead two to
one
yadier molina has announced
the one-two pitch
ground ball past the mound to the second
baseman mcmahon a run scores yachty's
out at first goldsmith crosses the plate
and the cardinals lead 3-1 paul de young
goes to third two down
o'neill hitless
last night
gonzalez the one-two pitch swing and a
miss got him with a breaking ball it
ends the inning but the cardinals scored
three first and third for chi-chi
gonzalez
gonzalez at the plate showing bunt
the pitch and it's blunted out in front
of the plate the runners trying to score
carlos shovels to yachty for the out
coming down the line connor joe is out
on the bunt by gonzalez two outs and the
cardinals still lead by two runs tapia
walked and scored in the first inning
the one strike pitch
that's chopped to the first baseman
goldsmith he fields it behind first
steps on the bag the rockies strand two
there's connor joe runners had first and
second
the one strike pitch to joe is grounded
to the left side arenado has it and he
throws across the diamond right on the
money joe hustling all the way
but he is out
and the two runners are stranded
one-on-one against carlson it'll be
carlson goldschmidt and arenado for st
louis in the third inning
and the next delivery is fouled off to
the left
and out of play what's this
oh wow
carlson singled to center
and now he's hit by the pitch
it was around the knee or leg area
somewhere and he's fine and he gets up
but that was just an errant delivery
from gonzalez that clipped carlson the
ball stayed at the plate so i figured it
had to hit something
and carlson was the only guy there
well the pressure squarely on
chi-chi gonzalez base is loaded and
yadier molina are the fans happy to have
him back listen
up the middle base hit off the glove of
mcmahon
one run is in here comes goldsmith to
the plate save
and yachty drives in two
three so far and counting in this game
and his return to the lineup
two runs in still only one out runners
at first and second for tyler o'neal
o'neal the right-hander swings and
grounds it to short story flips to
mcmahon for one on to first for the
double play and the cardinals will take
the two runs nunia is over his last nine
couple of strikeouts
swaying at him miss he struck him out
first strikeout for carlos martinez
second and third nobody out mcmahon up
right now second and third nobody out
the pitch
strike three called he went through the
back door with a slider to catch mcmahon
looking
great opportunity for hampton
the runners lead all the way around and
the pitch to hampson is swung on chopped
to third arnado throws home good stretch
by molina to get the out on topia
5-2 on the fielder's choice and then a
pitch in the dirt against connor joe and
the rockies will score a run as it
skipped away two on two out for the
rockies 3-2 pitch inside ball four
and that
reloads the bases
and dom nunez
coming to the plate here it comes
swinging a drive towards right center
field it's going to find a gap and go to
the wall
blackman and hampson home
and connor joe scores as well it's a
three-run double by dom nunez
and the game is tied at five
and here's the eighth man to bat in the
inning josh fuentes runner at second the
go-ahead run there's a pop-up on the
infield moving out into short left the
shortstop pauldy young he makes a
one-handed grab but the damage has been
done and here's paul goldschmidt who has
been on twice two for two an rbi two run
scored good time for a homer huh yep are
you calling it i'd like to see it well
everybody would like to see it i want to
know if you're calling it okay why not
okay
here's the 2-1
goldsmith
there it goes
two-run homer goldie who says it
thank you very much
the cardinals lead 7-5
on the strength of paul goldschmidt's
fifth home run of the year
garrett hampson plays up the middle of
the infield for paul de young
the pitch is swung on rip down the left
field line that's a fair ball
it's scoring nolan arnado and the
cardinals lead eight to five into second
with the rbi double paul de young
four hits in a row for the cardinals in
the fifth inning
tyler o'neal at the plate
the infield is in the 2-1 pitch
there's a fly ball center field dazza
makes the catch to young tags the throw
is somewhere over the rainbow safe at
the plate
a sacrifice fly for o'neal scoring to
young the cardinals have answered the
four-run top of the fifth with four runs
of their own
nine to five cardinals mcmahon
has a double and an rbi came back in the
first inning
2-1 is the count and the pitch is hit
into center field and that's dropping
dropping diving is bader and he makes
the catch he laid out in right center
field
and didn't quit on it
and made a terrific play helping out his
pitcher
gallegos so two outs and two on and
here's dom nunez
and the 2-2 delivery is grounded to the
right side and the young's gonna catch
that ball on the right side of second
base and throw out nunez and that'll do
it for the rockies time to stretch
harrison bader homer yesterday
this afternoon one for three a line out
a pop out and a single
this is down the line
and a long throw to first is in time
nice play by ryan mcmahon
rymel tapia heading to the plate now
rymel with
a base hit back in the fifth inning to
extend his hitting streak he's also
walked and scored on the day one for
three officially
the pitch
driven down the right side headed
towards the corner not able to cut it
off carlson will play it but it'll be an
rbi double for rymel tapia and the
rockies make it nine to six as they
close in on the cardinals
it'll leave it up to charlie blackmon
gallegos
breaking ball hit into center field
that's a base hit home comes tapia story
right behind him throw is off line but
blackman will hold it first a two run
single
charlie blackman makes it a one-run game
9-8 st louis
and garrett hampson at the plate and the
1-2 delivery is hit a line drive caught
by paul deyoung
a liner about head high to paul deyoung
he moved a step to his left and made the
play to end the inning
de young
has walked twice on the day
2-2 pitch
fastball popped up on the infield
gibbons will catch it himself
and michael strands the bases loaded
now matt adams
the rockies are down to their last
strike the pitch adams swings and misses
for a redbird winner